>> Tucker: SO YOU HAVE SEEN
THIS BEFORE, YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE IT AGAIN ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, LEGISLATION PENDING IN
STATE HOUSE IN DELAWARE WOULD
ALLOW CHILDREN TO GET ABORTIONS
OR CHANGES WITHOUT NOTIFYING
THEIR PARENT, SO THE PARENTS
INSURANCE WOULD PAY FOR THIS
WITH THE PARENTS DON'T HAVE A
RIGHT TO KNOW.
DEMOCRATS BACK THERE'S A BILL,
OF COURSE, AND SAY FLAT OUT
ABORTION AND GENDER TRANSITION
RELATED SERVICES ARE COVERED.
SO YOUR KIDS CAN HAVE ABORTIONS
AND SEX CHANGES AND DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS IN DELAWARE AND MANY
OTHER STATES DON'T WANT YOU TO
KNOW ABOUT IT.
SO, IF THERE WAS EVER AN EFFORT
TO DESTROY THE NUCLEAR FAMILY
THIS OBVIOUS, WE ARE NOT AWARE
OF WHAT IT MIGHT BE.
TERRY SCHILLING IS THE PRESIDENT
OF THE AMERICAN PRINCIPLES
PROJECT AND JOINS US TONIGHT TO
ASSESS.
TERRY, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
YOU KNOW, THE PARENTS
RELATIONSHIP WITH HIS OR HER
CHILDREN IS SACROSANCT.
POLITICIANS AREN'T ALLOWED TO
GET IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT, YOU
WOULD THINK.
AND YET, DEMOCRATS IN DELAWARE
AND MANY OTHER STATES ARE TRYING
TO DESTROY THAT RELATIONSHIP.
WHO IS FIGHTING BACK AGAINST
THIS?
>> WELL, THERE ARE PARENTS
PRIMARILY THAT ARE FIGHTING BACK
AGAINST THIS, TUCKER, AND THEY
ARE BEING ORGANIZED PRIMARILY AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL.
THERE ARE EFFORTS OF THE
NATIONAL LEVEL.
MY ORGANIZATION, AMERICAN
PRINCIPLES PRODUCT KNOW MY
PROJECT IS BUILDING WHAT WE CALL
THE NRA FOR FAMILIES BUT
ULTIMATELY THIS IS GOING TO BE
ABOUT PARENTS TAKING CONTROL OF
THEIR KIDS EDUCATION DIRECTLY.
WE HAVE TO MAKE THESE PEOPLE PAY
A POLITICAL PRICE WHEN THEY HURT
OUR FAMILIES.
TUCKER, YOU SAID IT BEST, THIS
IS REALLY ABOUT ABOLISHING THE
FAMILY.
THE PROGRESSIVES WOULD SAY THEY
ARE LIBERATING CHILDREN FROM THE
PARENTAL CONSTRAINTS AND THE
PARENTAL OPPRESSION AND THE
PATRIARCHY.
REALLY, THEY ARE DESTROYING
THEM.
THEIR GOAL IS TO LIBERATE THESE
CHILDREN TO ACHIEVE FULL EQUITY
AND FULL EQUALITY AND THEY WILL
ACHIEVE THAT.
WE WILL JUST ALL BE EQUALLY
MISERABLE AND TERRIBLE AND SAD.
IT WILL DESTROY THE COUNTRY,
DESTROY THE ECONOMY COME AND
DESTROY US AS INDIVIDUALS IF WE
ALLOW THESE STATES TO DO THIS,
AND IT IS IMPORTANT, TUCKER, TO
PAY ATTENTION TO DELAWARE.
THEY ARE ON THE CUTTING-EDGE,
THEY WERE THE FIRST STATE IN THE
NATION TO CODIFY ROE.
NATION TO REDEFINE PARENTHOOD,
WELL BEFORE GAME MARRIAGE
PASSED.
WHAT HAPPENS IN DELAWARE ENDS UP
SPREADING TO OTHER STATES.
>> Tucker: YEAH, I MEAN, THEY
HATE THEIR FATHERS, THAT IS THE
BASIS OF THEIR POLITICS, I GET
IT, BUT THAT DOES NOT GIVE THEM
A RIGHT TO MESS WITH OUR KIDS.
THEY ALWAYS WANT TO MESS WITH
YOUR KIDS.
WHY -- YOU KNOW, WHY NOT PICK ON
ADULTS?
WHY DO THEY HAVE TO TAKE YOUR
CHILDREN, BRAINWASH THEM, CANCEL
YOUR FAMILY TIES TO YOUR OWN
KIDS, YOUR PARENTAL AUTHORITY,
WHY CAN'T WE JUST DRAW A LINE AT
OUR CHILDREN, I WONDER?
>> WELL, BECAUSE CHILDREN ARE
VERY VULNERABLE TO IDEAS, RIGHT?
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ECOSYSTEM
PROGRESSIVES HAVE CREATED, IT IS
A FULL-FLEDGED ECOSYSTEM, AND IT
IS NOT -- THE STORY IS MUCH
BIGGER THAN JUST WHAT THE
LEGISLATION WILL DO TO INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND THE EXPLANATION OF
BENEFITS.
WHAT NO ONE IS TALKING ABOUT IS
THESE SCHOOLS IN DELAWARE ALL
HAVE SCHOOL-BASED HEALTH
CLINICS, AND WHEN PARENTS
SIGN -- YOU KNOW THEY SIGN THE
PERMISSION SLIPS OF THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR, SIGNING
AWAY A BUNCH OF CONSENT FORMS,
THEY SIGN A CONSENT FORM THAT
ALLOWS THE SCHOOL-BASED HEALTH
CLINICS TO TREAT THEIR CHILDREN,
AND THEY GIVE AWAY THEIR RIGHTS
TO STOP THEM, AND I THINK MOST
PARENTS THINK IT IS GOING TO BE
IBUPROFEN OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT,
BUT IT IS MUCH WORSE.
BUT KIDS ARE SUSCEPTIBLE TO
THESE IDEAS.
ESPECIALLY THESE LITTLE KIDS
WITH THE SEX ED CLASSES AND
GENDER IDENTITY CLASSES.
THEY STILL BELIEVE IN
SANTA CLAUS, RIGHT?
>> Tucker: IT IS -- MORE THAN
A MILLION AMERICANS HAVE PULLED
THEIR KIDS OUT OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS
IN THE LAST YEAR.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A COLLAPSE
OF